I see possible Futures all at once and
in so many Futures our enemies
Prevail but I do see a way there is a
narrow way
[Applause]
through Hello friends my name is n PR
you're watching the big ticket interview
for June part two and as you can see no
unattractive people were allowed in the
making of This film it's crazy to think
about the journey this story has been on
to make it to the big screen Frank
Herbert's epic sci-fi novel that
inspired a whole genre was denied 22
times by editors who thought it was too
complex in the 70s Alejandra yod rowski
tried to give us the coolest Dune movie
never made and then in the 80s we got a
dune film but some fans thought that it
didn't quite capture all of the story so
as I was coming here I was thinking
about how man it's been 60 years that
fans have been waiting to see Paul
atraes try and fulfill his prophecy
Timothy I want to start with you because
you play Paul and I want to ask you
about that pressure and him confronting
that prophecy because the greatest gift
Dune has ever given me is the litany
against fear I must not fear fear is the
mind killer tell us about confronting
that prophecy you know from part one to
part two the becoming of what he becomes
and how you were able to fully commit to
that but still hold humility while
taking Direction in a scene man thank
you for such a beautiful question yeah
and thank you for such a an intro that
honors the the book and all the previous
versions made and unmade and uh I think
the easy answer is was in Denise hands
and it's he's the most passionate of all
of us I think about this material and uh
this is uh we see Paul tradies here and
you actually had the correct
pronunciation there when you say a traes
I remember that from the pamphlet we got
when we started the first one and U did
you say it a different way first well
people say Paul a tradies you know but
in the you know in the Frank Herbert
pronunciation it is a traes how you said
it um and uh this this second film is is
the becoming like you put it you know
it's it ties the loose ends of the first
movie and we see Paul go from the sort
of boyish figure from the first one and
steps into the second one fatherless and
and becomes the man that he needs to be
whether he's ready for it or not was
that daunting for you stepping into like
the Big M absolutely and uh all the more
so because of everyone I'm on this couch
with sincerely looking up to everyone
here you know and uh watching No Country
for Old Men for stupidly the first time
right before we started this one and
realizing what Titans these two were
beyond the work there I already knew so
man a huge pressure but honestly I love
everything I've been in but this might
be the project I'm most proud of because
for all the reasons you listed and just
it's cool to be in the theater and feel
like I don't know how I'm in this and
and just really admire the movie and
admire Denise it's like one of these
movies man yeah can I tell you that uh
watching you rise as a leading man of my
generation has been so beautiful to
witness wow and the way that you carried
the first film like fans cannot wait to
see you in this movie like I'm looking
I'm waiting for like Nike to drop some
Messiah Dune dunks because you're just
that would be sick too you know um I've
heard you say before in an interview
that Chie Paul's love interest is really
his moral compass otherwise a messiah
prophecy would be too abstract right and
Zinda you play Chie and Chie and Paul
are literally like sci-fi Romeo and
Juliet you know I was reading that you
shot scenes with Timothy in Abu Dhabi
and Jordan as the sun was going down and
I was thinking man like the pressure to
to relax into Romance when you're
pressed for time and like how are they
flirting in futuristic space talk like
is he wooing her with a sandwalk you
know what I mean like we were trying to
figure that out too you know definely I
think Denny was also trying to figure
that out but I think what he's so
brilliant at which I think uh is so
impressive is while the movie is so
massive and there's so much to cover
there's so much to like you say honor
right and everybody has their own you
know storyline their own moments but he
always is able to find the human moments
which is what guides us through
everything and and carve out those
things that feel like no matter what
planet you're on you feel connected and
you feel like like it's it's your own um
and so I don't know I think he I think
we all were trying to figure out how do
we balance so much happening to these
characters so such intense stakes and
you know
um while also allowing them to just be
young people that are like having this
like romance and whatever and um and
it's and it's conflicting and it's
painful and it's confusing because Paul
represents something that to her is
everything she despises you know so wow
um can you tell us about bringing their
epic love to life in this because it is
the center of the film um I think trust
trust in Denny yeah I think he's he's we
always kind of go back to that he he's
uh I think more than anyone he
understands the material through and
through because he loves it like he he I
know he like he said that he signed like
his yearbook muad right so it's like he
really loves this so when you're um when
you're asking him a question he's
already thought of it like 10 times over
so all the worries I have he's already
had them you know by the time I get
there and it's so nice to know that
you're in safe hands and you can ask
those questions and be in those moments
and and figure it out and also know that
you can experiment and have fun while
also like being their structure and
there's support and there's a vision
already there too um so yeah I think we
just trust trust that he knows he knows
he'll guide us you know yeah how would
you describe their love in part two um I
feel like it's it's um I would I I would
say the Love Story isn't given right
it's earned because uh like I said he
represents to her everything that she
um that that that that represents pain
pain right and and and hurt and fear and
so when she's confronted with the
feeling of like oh wait a minute I think
I I I love this person that's like the
the separation between mind and heart
and how do
you H how do you accept both of those
things at once you know and I don't
without giving anything away or or
ruining it for anyone whether you've SE
read the books or not you know it it it
is um there's a lot of sacrifices that
have to be made you know for something
that's bigger than than everyone so
everybody has to sacrifice something a
little piece of their heart or big piece
you know um wow but yeah it's I mean
it's it's there's so much to talk like
there's so much you can keep going and
going and going you know there's so much
to talk about um but like like he said
I'm just so grateful to be here with
these I mean yeah these talented people
it's like you know the whole thing doing
it pinch me and you're always just like
wow I can't believe I'm here I know I
speak for a lot of people and I say
people can't wait to see more of chny in
part two and Z you are so effortless and
yet such a force and those feel like
such opposing energies right but you
just like make it happen so I cannot
wait uh while we're on the topic of
romance uh Florence you are no stranger
to sharing romantic scenes with Mr
Timothy sham here and films like Little
Women uh people are fans are so excited
to see you guys ever do rtic scenes I
was reading that you guys had to be
separated on set cuz you were having so
much fun and I know you like calling him
shamala Bing Bong so excited calls him
bang bong so yeah know how much you
respect your grandparents I love my
grand respect to the Grand I was going
to say you obviously play Princess rulan
daughter of shadam Emperor 4th played by
the legendary Christopher Walkin uh can
you tell us and maybe tease what her
relationship with their fathers like and
what excited you most about this
character aside from like the fire head
dresses that you get to wear yes that
was one thing that I did do that for
when I was reading the script I was like
I'm going to get some killer costumes um
but yeah I play Princess Anan who is um
the emperor's daughter and she's in the
middle of this Dynamic of um people
either trying to gain power or keep hold
of power and I think she lands bangs
back in the middle of uh learning that
and learning from her father and I I was
trying to explain yesterday that I think
this is the most different of characters
that I've ever played because even
though she is opinionated and and
intelligent and feisty it never comes
out of her she's constantly watching Ing
and listening and and waiting and she's
very I suppose making a calculated move
internally constantly because she has to
and she's been trained that way so I
think weirdly enough she's probably been
one of the quietest of characters I've
played um but probably the most exciting
because there is a future and you don't
quite know what that is what she's
thinking so I think I've I've definitely
been able to just sit and and watch all
of these people um and uh and learn from
them in scenes as well because that is
kind of what she's doing as well so I've
had a I've had a great time and yeah I
get to I get to be his um his boo
again I can't wait for that director uh
Denny VNV said that you have this innate
royalness to you and like having met you
I feel like that rings so true and I
can't wait to see I read that and I was
like what is he on about I swear I was
either na he was like you're going to be
prime minister one day I was I was I was
either napping on set wearing my chain
mail or I was feeding people
food that's incredible wonderful thing
to read yeah I can't wait to see your
princess in part two uh equally as
excited Austin Butler to see your fade
rotha Harkin in I mean I'm so obsessed
with your dedication of getting into
character on day one of readthrough
you're already talking like a hekinan
you're training for four months with a
former Navy SEAL to become what Denny
called a cross between a psychotic
sociopath serial killer and MC Jagger
which is so sick because we almost saw
MC Jagger play this role in yod rasi's
June but we see how psychotic is when
he's like licking a knife how did you
decide to portray this villain and tell
us about that licking the knife
scene uh I mean it all starts with Dene
you know as as as everybody here I think
can attest to it's that and and going I
I had read the novel when I was a
teenager and so I I'd kind of had an
idea and then talking to den and seeing
the first film and knowing the texture
that he was playing within and and and
how fade would fit into the tapestry
that had already been laid
um it really just provided so much room
for play and so I I don't even remember
the licking of the knife moment I think
that may have been a Dene idea where you
know we were always just trying to find
these idiosyncrasies and and who fade
was and um and there is this kind of
seductive sick thing about him that uh I
think kind of fit into that moment wow
so you don't remember looking the knife
I I I remember I just don't remember
where that that idea came from he just
does it all the time he conly doing that
yeah testing testing the sharpness of
knives so as you do as you do Austin
Butler speaking of knives Javier you're
like the Spanish army knife of acting
like you've played everything uh Denise
said Thank you you're welcome Denise
said that your charisma like explodes in
part two which I don't even know how
that's possible
because that like I mean remind me how
to ask you how to get out of a speeding
ticket later cuz I just feel like you're
so charismatic you play sgar who is in
the fman and he takes Paul under his
wing Because he believes Paul's a
messiah and he's like a father figure
what does Paul's ride on a sand worm
mean to the fman and did you get to ride
one because I know that that was your
dream uh I I I think the relationship
with Paul is is the relationship of a
man who starts to really discover him
for what he is in reality and for what
he wishes him to be uh based on
religious fanatism so it goes parallel
what he feels and what he expects of him
and that Arc is beautifully written and
done in the movie and allows us to
create a nice relationship of a father
figure Mentor but also become something
else very powerful in the in the sense
that he still worships him to a point
where he's absolutely
blinded uh and and uh and and that
speaks about religion in the sense that
the religion fanatism is not something
that uh is a joke I mean that's that
that's what creates what what what
creates so um it's a powerful character
in the sense that he changes
dramatically through the story from the
beginning where he sees this new kid in
town until he really gets on his knees
uh in front of him and did you get to
ride a sand worm I did I did and uh that
was a promise made by Deni back in the
day and he contractual he the lever it's
the only reason he did the
move he the lever um Timothy you have to
tell me what it was like first time
riding a sand worm because that scene in
the trailer is just insane well there
was a whole worm unit on the movie
literally called the worm unit they shot
you know uh if I'm right there's a
two-minute sequence in the movie or
something like that that took them four
months to shoot or something insane and
uh I don't know I I I don't know how to
describe it it was uh it was absolutely
insane and uh obviously the worm wasn't
there on the day so there is a certain
process of visualization but they built
I thought was fascinating they built
very uh you know specifically what you
know a tiny part of the worm would would
uh sounds
weird would look like slab worm a little
slab of worm skin one says that's even
weirder you just kind of yeah hook into
it yeah yeah I don't know how what did
it feel like it felt it was exhilarating
and um and uh yes there all these
innuendos no but but um was something
that I feel like I don't want to speak
for Den I don't think they had fully
figured out at the end of the first one
there's a visual at a distance at the
end of the movie of someone writing sand
warm so I think they were sort of
figuring out but there was definitely a
technique to it you know I remember you
know going to Z and you know wishing
that my arm technique was different wait
why because um just you know visuals
there's there's a real frame of
reference for writing a sand so you're
trying to do it cool you know and make
it look strong and so you're trying to
like okay do I hold like this do I stand
like this do I have my leg here do I you
know you're trying to have the strongest
worm writing pose at the end of the day
you know cuz it is it's film making you
know so you you're trying to figure it
out figure it out not just any weird
gameo
no no no well they see you all of
it it's not me it's not
you oh man that's incredible and just
seeing you the queen of poses like dude
like that was everything figure it out I
feel like we're all like just foaming at
the mouth for the action in part two and
Josh I was actually laughing when I was
reading about you talking about how you
and Javier were in full diet mode at the
Oscars and prep for this film um panic
mode panic mode it was a diet it was a
panic
that's hilarious uh it is such a
pleasure to meet you Josh I've always
wanted to tell you that I think you have
the greatest military face of all time
so it's an honor to interview you as
gurn H it's a great thing in my house um
gurny halik so cool trusted adviser to
Paul and House of Trades but on his days
off he plays an instrument called the
ballis set we were deprived of a scene
in part one but I heard we're getting
one in part two so what can you tell us
about that scene and did you guys ever
have any like Dune campfire like music
music nights with the biset I would have
or without the biset no we didn't we
didn't it sounds actually fun though to
have like to be practicing the biset the
first one that Deni cut out cuz we did
it and it was right at the last second
he was like Hey we're going to do the
scene tomorrow morning can you learn the
lyrics and all that so that was one
thing and I don't think it was because
of that it was just tonally totally off
and I agreed but he went down like a big
shame spiral and I'm so sorry and I'm
going do this and that and then this one
came up and for whatever reason cuz Greg
Fraser and I had done a book of my
writing in Greg's
photography uh obviously revolving
around the first dune and then so he was
privy to the writing so once this came
up he said I want you and Hans to
collaborate on the
song and you know it sounds cool it's a
little
unnerving simmer and then so I was
sitting there for a month or a month and
a half right writing lyrics and sending
Deni lyrics and sending Hans lyrics and
Hans was on vacation and then he would
send me back like a picture of a of an
iceberg or something or like a really
nice Sunset and I was like yeah I need
to work on the song send me the music to
the song so he would send me music once
in a while and it was wrong and then it
got so familiar that I was like I don't
know if Hans is right for this
movie and then eventually I saw the
movie and lyrics are good they're okay
and the music's brilliant it's genius so
yeah he made he makes me look
really that is an incredible story you
can feel the fun you guys are having Vis
early in part one you know it's felt
through orchestrated by some of you
Denny's Direction Greg Frasier
cinematography Han Zimmer score but
Denny called this one a cinematic blast
actually so I wanted to ask the both of
you what do you think he meant by that
and why is this a film that that you
have to see on the big screen what he
meant by that is there's a my guess is
there's a certain level of World
building in the first one that is ultra
detailed but it's laying the groundwork
and here this is like the skyscraper
that goes on the concrete it's full of
action not to put it lightly or you know
in a bol way and it's epic and not to
again use that word in some silly way
it's epic it's like on a huge scale it's
done with Integrity it's done with heart
it's felt you know everyone here these
like amazing actors really brought their
aame and it's a Sci-Fi material with in
the hands of the best director so it's
legitimized in some way not that it
needs legitimizing but anyway it's uh
it's it's it's a great one it's an
experience on the big screen you
actually get to be there you get to feel
the the the drums and the running and
the guns and your seats like you are at
the edge of your seat from the moment
you start watching it to the very end I
mean I wept when I was when I was
looking at the credits of the of the CGI
team because there was this like
beautiful score that Hans had done and I
was just like look at all these people
that made this movie the respect for
every single person that that worked on
that movie is so high and it's because
everybody gave a damn and wanted to be
there and wanted to create the same the
same thing the same beautiful experience
that we all witnessed on the first and
then but this time it's bigger it's epic
it's an experience there's only one way
to watch this movie and it's like there
with
speakers yes I can't wait and before I
go I have to ask um because after Frank
Herbert wrote Dune a lot of fans thought
of Paul as a hero and so according to
Denny he wrote Dune Messiah to prove
that it was actually a warning uh Denny
has said he has words on paper for a
part three for those of you who play
characters in that book would you be
down and and what type of story do you
think Denny would tell would we be down
I mean of course yeah was like n we're
all tapping out
now I think I think you know any time
den he calls it's a yes for me at least
you know um he's he he I mean I'm I'm
excited to see what what happens I mean
I I started Messiah and I was like whoa
okay let me I'm only we're shooting the
first movie let me just go back to the
first one you know cuz it's so much to
to take in and I think there's no better
hands with better care and and um and
love for it than than him so I think
just excited to see like you know we're
all just like it's it's just like
anticipation you know whenever he's
ready I know he's like a perfectionist
in many ways and doesn't want to share
things unless he's fully ready to do
that so respecting that and wait till
he's ready well at its core dun is the
story of Prophecy and fate versus Free
Will and I can say confidently that I
think it was fate that you all were
chosen um to tell this story so thank
you so much for putting
into it and do it and thank you guys so
much for watching tickets to Doom part
two we on sale right now on fang.com my
name is as Perez and hopefully I will
see you next time in a pair of Nike
Messiah thanks to you those are
amazing guys than
you